being a young filmmaker I've you know
I've met a lot of people who say they
want to do this but they want to do this
they want to do that but they don't
they're not accountable they're not
reliable they don't show up for a
meeting they don't they get could they
come to an audition unprepared I've had
so many actors say if you ever have a
part for me keep me in mind I say
absolutely so I'll send them a script
let's say in the book I'm doing this
movie I'll send them script and say hey
this is what I'm doing and they won't
read it and then a month later they'll
say if you have anything in mind for me
I see you're doing a movie and I'll
think I sent you a script a month ago
did you read it oh I got to get around
to it if I was a young actor and I
wanted to act and I and a filmmaker who
has made films before and worked with
these people sent me a script I would be
on that reading it's and putting myself
on videotape doing this doing that but
people just aren't hungry enough and I
have no I lose respect for people like
that and I just I just it's too
competitive my time is too valuable and
I have you know I look up to so many
people who work their butts off who do
not get their fair opportunity and I
feel like I haven't given been given my
fair shot yet in this industry and
that's fine because I'm not going
anywhere I'm here to stay what I feel
bad for are the people that have the
skill that have the talent but they have
other things out of their control
holding them back maybe they they aren't
they're under a severe financial stress
they're they have other things in their
life that is keeping them from pursuing
this full-time you know I've been
fortunate that I am in a position to
continue to do this and to keep plugging
away but I don't have sympathy for the
people who are in a position to do this
who have the resources who have the
support of family and friends they say
they're an actor they say they're this
or that but they do nothing to
demonstrate it and unfortunately you
have millions of people like that out
here and it waters down the good ones
and that's why everyone and their
brother wants to make a movie and you
know and everyone their brother is on
Kickstarter or IndieGoGo and everyone
and their brother is submitting films to
Sundance you know
and that's my true feeling about it
you